room
after 14 unsuccessful attempts over the
course of last week Kevin McCarthy has
finally been elected Speaker of the
House of Representatives but not before
caving to pretty much all of the
conservative holdouts demands including
just to name a handful a southern Border
Protection Plan a budget that stops an
increase in the debt ceiling an end to
all covid mandates and funding a select
committee to investigate the
weaponization of the FBI and other
agencies a term limit vote a minimum
72-hour reading period before bills are
brought to a vote permission for single
subject bills and increased voice for
the freedom caucus conservatives on the
most important committees and most
consequently probably the biggest
sticking point for both McCarthy and the
holdouts a return to the former
Congressional Norm of allowing any
member to call a vote to boot the
speaker from his spot
despite all the rancor and all the
turmoil and all the gnashing of teeth
from The Establishment about those evil
conservative holdouts
the outcome of this little fight has
been as good as anyone could ask for
especially at a time when Democrats
control the White House and the Senate
McCarthy gets his coveted title and the
hard-line conservatives get pretty much
everything else I'm Michael Knowles it's
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment Friday is from Rachel gunning
who says listened to this while going to
the gym for the first time in two years
I love that it's my favorite comment
because I really like that I am their
inspiring experiencing with you as you
make an effort to improve yourself I
hope you work out for the two of us I
certainly have not been hitting the gym
in the new year maybe maybe soon enough
though I'm really really inspired to
hear that it's good stuff that's that is
how you're gonna improve your personal
life it's how you're going to improve
your professional life when you want to
improve your professional life you gotta
check out ZipRecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles the daily wire
is looking to fill a few new roles here
in 2023 including VP of paid media
senior publicist and Senior network
engineer if you aren't like us and need
to hire for your business and you want
an easier way to find qualified
candidates head on over to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles try it for free
ZipRecruiter uses powerful technology to
find the right eight candidates for your
job see a candidate you like well you
can easily send them a personal
invitation so they're more likely to
apply their user friendly dashboard
makes it easy to filter review and rate
your candidates all from one place let
zip recruiter help you find the best
people for all your roles four out of
five employers who post on ZipRecruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself go to
ziprecruiter.com
to try ZipRecruiter for free that is
ziprecruiter.com
[Music]
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ZipRecruiter is simply the
smartest way to hire that is
ziprecruiter.com Knowles
one of the big conservative holdouts
on the McCarthy speakership was Chip Roy
who is one of my absolute favorite
members of Congress here is Chip Roy on
CNN
articulating what the conservatives got
well first of all you know let's
remember that a little temporary
conflict is necessary in this town in
order to stop this town from rolling
over the American people I don't think
anybody on either side of the aisle
could say with a straight face that they
think that Washington is doing uh good
work for the American people on a
regular basis and isn't broken uh it we
we have to work to fix this place and
look some of the tensions you saw on
display uh when we saw some of the you
know the interactions there between Mike
Rogers and Matt Gates uh you know some
of that is we need a little of that we
need a little of this sort of breaking
the glass in order to get us to the
table in orders to fight for the
American people and to change the way
this place is dysfunctional so this all
started going back last summer we wanted
rules to open this place up we wanted
more transparency we wanted more
openness more ability to add amendments
to the floor so for example you ask what
else did we get we got amendments to be
able to I'm sorry we got the ability to
offer amendments on the floor of the
house during Appropriations that will
open it up again we haven't done that so
since I've been in Congress I've not
been able to offer an amendment on the
floor
just one example one really great point
he says look this there was this
Congressional Norm then it went away the
whole time I've been in Congress we
haven't been able to do this really
basic thing it takes power away from the
representatives which means it takes
power away from the people the whole
point of the House of Representatives is
to give the people power and so this was
a real Improvement this is what I was
saying from the beginning I felt the the
most absurd argument from the GOP
establishment was
these conservatives they don't even know
what they're asking for
that's that was the line that you heard
from The Establishment that was trying
to put McCarthy into power as quickly as
possible and quash the conservatives
they said well I don't they don't even
have demands we don't even know what
they want yes we do chip Roy articulated
just one point that they wanted I I laid
out from representative Scott Perry a
whole list of things in my introduction
that they not only wanted and asked for
but ended up getting and then last week
I had Lauren bobert on the show and the
reason I had my friend Lauren bobert on
the show is because I saw that she and
some of her other conservative holdout
comrades were going on the TV shows but
then the the hosts wouldn't let them
talk
so the conservatives would go on the TV
shows and those would say well what do
you want see there they say well I think
actually it would be nice yeah you don't
you don't know what you want you can't
articulate anything you guys just need
to go and vote for McCarthy well
actually if you just let me speak I
think ah come on you people what do you
want what are you actually gonna get and
and so I I said okay Lauren come on the
show tell us what's going on here what's
the background
what do you want and surprise surprise
when you let the conservative speak
they're actually pretty articulate
they're actually pretty reasonable they
actually do kind of have a plan and the
plan in this case largely worked they
did not stop McCarthy from becoming
speaker one of the big reasons that they
were not able to do that is that nobody
else wanted the job because it's kind of
a terrible job and it messes up people's
political careers trajectories if they
want to go in a different direction so
Jim Jordan for instance was put up as a
name Jim Jordan said emphatically I will
not take this job
Jim Jordan said what Paul Ryan probably
should have said when they came to him
on this issue the last time that this
came up
2015. John Boehner steps down Kevin
McCarthy was The Heir Apparent the
conservatives didn't want McCarthy he
said okay we need a compromise candidate
how about Paul Ryan Paul Ryan accepted
it
it destroyed his political career now
he's in no man's land he's persona non
grata so Jim Jordan and some other names
who were floated they said no I'm not
taking that I'm going to keep on doing
exactly what I'm doing
I'm gonna keep on fighting on the
Judiciary Committee or on this committee
or on that committee and so there was
not a great alternative to McCarthy who
could get those kinds of votes so the
second best option was they get all of
the demands that they asked for McCarthy
and that that is what happened so where
do we go from here
again not to say I told you so you know
I hate to say I told you so but while
the establishment was telling us that
this was the the end of the GOP oh we're
so embarrassed we're so humiliated we're
all infighting we can't get anything
done this is the this is the greatest
collapse why are we clutching defeat
from the jaws of victory
I said guys
it'll be okay they're big boys this is a
political fight in Congress that's what
they do in Congress and yes the rhetoric
gets a little bit heated and yes you
hear the conservatives calling Kevin
McCarthy the biggest squish sellout
Rhino that you ever heard in the world
and from the team that was Pro McCarthy
you heard some pretty heated rhetoric as
well in fact my friend Dan Crenshaw
referred to the conservatives as
terrorists last week and now now that
the negotiation is over now that the
fight is over Dan went on see also went
on CNN like shipper I did and said okay
the terrorist thing all right maybe I
went a little bit far
you opened up with the whole terrorist
comments I do have to address that
please
um look things get heated and things get
said
obviously to the people who took offense
by that it's pretty obvious that it's
meant as a turn of phrase in the it's a
metaphor it's in the context of
intransient negotiations I look I've got
pretty thick skin I'm called awful vile
things by the kind of the very same wing
of the party that that I'm fighting I
was fighting at that moment so I was a
little taken aback by by the uh
sensitivity yeah by the sensitivity of
it but
um to the extent that I had colleagues
that were that were offended by it I
sincerely apologize to them I don't want
them to think I actually believe they're
terrorists it's clearly a turn of phrase
that you use and what is an intransient
negotiation
there you go as far as politicians go
that was about the most direct apology
you're ever going to get and good on Dan
for apologizing I agree I think that
rhetoric was a little bit overheated it
happens it's a political fight that's
Washington DC the sky is not going to
fall in if the conservatives hold out
for a few days and get some more
concessions out of the speaker
the sky it's okay these are Big Boys Dan
Crenshaw said it right there he said
look I got thick skin obviously the
guy's an abcl
all these other members of Congress
they've got thick skin Kevin McCarthy
he's got thick skin it's okay that's
what we send them there to do and the
first test of a speaker is can you get
the votes eventually he could and he the
only way he was able to do it was by
going back on his previous bet
McCarthy's previous bet was he didn't
need the conservatives from the freedom
caucus to win his speakership because of
the way the election turned out in
November he ended up needing those
conservatives and he paid a price for
his Bad Bet and that price has been to
the benefit of the conservatives and of
the Republican party and of the American
people good stuff now we can all kiss
make up Move Along gummy up the system
for the Democrats put forward some
conservative proposals investigate the
Dems expose the corruption in the
executive agencies which was a big
a big conservative win in this whole
negotiation
absolutely great stuff we got another
big win from the appeals court
a federal appeals court on Friday
just struck down the ban on bump stocks
do you remember the bump stock ban the
bump stock ban actually occurred under
Trump
I love Donald Trump best president of my
lifetime but he had a few big missteps
this was one of the big missteps where
president Trump
basically asked the ATF to ban bump
stocks didn't go through a normal
legislative Channel and what is a bump
stock a bump stock is this little
addition you put onto your gun that
allows you to fire the gun somewhat more
quickly at the time the ATF argued that
this turned semi-automatic weapons one
pull of the trigger one bullet comes out
into machine guns pull the trigger once
and a spray of bullets come come out if
you have ever shot a bump stock you know
that's not actually how that that works
in fact you can replicate a bump stock
even without any additional technology
on your gun if you hold it in a certain
way and you have your finger in a
certain way you can you can replicate
the motion which is that you use the
recoil of the gun to fire the trigger
multiple times but it was always
Preposterous and and the appeals court
not not in a particularly close decision
this was 13-3 just struck down that band
so this is a major win for the Second
Amendment I hope a good sign as we move
into the first time in a couple of years
where we've had any Republican control
of
the legislative or executive branches of
the government this this is something
that gives me a little bit of peace but
when I want troopies I pray a great way
to pray hello right now go to hallow.com
Knowles if you are listening to this
show you know that I consider religion
to be a pretty important thing that is
why I'm so excited to talk to you about
hello hello is the number one Christian
Prayer app and the number one Catholic
app in the world I love hello the app
has everything I need to maintain a
daily prayer routine it's got over 6 000
audio guided prayers meditations and
peaceful music playlists plus daily
reminders will encourage you to keep up
with the routine you know maybe about a
couple of fellas I like maybe um father
Mike Schmitz would be an example of
someone on here how about Mark Wahlberg
well you can listen to father Mike
schmitz's Bible and ear podcast on
hallow you can pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim Caviezel Jonathan Rooney
who plays Jesus in the new streaming
series The Chosen just as with physical
exercise daily spiritual exercise is
critical to your well-being
especially in a world where attacks on
religion are happening all around us
every day try hallow for three months
free at hallow.com Knowles that is
hello.com Knowles
we got some good news from the courts on
striking down the bump stock ban we've
got some bad news from the courts
a grand jury has just declined to indict
a man who attacked Ted Cruz
you might remember this you might not
remember this
Ted Cruz was going through some kind of
Rally or parade and a guy threw I
believe a white claw can at Cruz's face
so this was a 33 year old guy Joseph
hallm Archie diaco now that's too bad I
guess he's Italian very frustrating he
was charged with aggravated assault with
a deadly weapon uh then was instead no
build according to court documents the
grand jury quote now asks the court to
discharge and release this defendant
from custody according to a filing from
The District Court of Harris County
what does this mean the only reason I
mentioned this I did not think they were
going to throw this guy in prison I did
not think they would go after him really
at all and now
those of us who doubted that stuff would
happen have been proven right why
because the government has been
encouraging the public to attack
prominent conservatives for years that's
why that's how we knew that this was
going to happen because Maxine Waters
goes out and says you get up on those
Republicans you push back on them in
public you go to their homes you say
they're not wanted here you get Chuck
Schumer outside the Supreme Court saying
we're coming for you Kavanaugh we're
coming for you Gorsuch then you get a
would-be assassin takes a bus from
California and tries to murder Brett
Kavanaugh possibly his family this is
what you see you see mobs pushing up on
Mitch McConnell in public you see mobs
pushing up on Ted Cruz in public
again and again on Mitch McConnell on
Elaine Chao on on all of these prominent
conservatives and and it's done with the
encouragement of the Democrats Hillary
Clinton at the time said you can't be
civil with people who want to destroy
your political agenda you can't okay you
can't be civil so I guess you've got to
be
uncivil you got to be you have to be
violent with them is what she was saying
this
ties in I think with another story that
we'll try to get to a little bit later
today
Ashley Babbitt we just came up on the
anniversary of Ashley Babbitt's death
Ashley Babbitt was a trump supporter who
showed up to the Capitol on January 6th
and yes was going into an area that she
should not have been going into and
obviously there was a lot of unruly
riotous behavior that day and a trigger
happy Capitol Hill cop shot her shot her
dead Ashley Babbitt was unarmed
there was no real threat from this young
woman the cop did not face any
consequences whatsoever was not fired
was not charged didn't what I don't even
think he got a slap on the wrist
not a p people say oh it's a good that's
a wonderful thing
Ted someone throws a beer can a Ted Cruz
or a white claw Cannon Ted Cruz no big
deal it's nothing let the guy completely
off the hook does anybody really believe
if any conservative
physically assaulted or killed a
Democrat
that that would just be written off okay
no big deal
no of course not
of course not you would have nationwide
protests she would have George Floyd 2.0
consider the case of George Floyd a
career criminal was committing a crime
and resisting arrest and had a lethal
dose of drugs in his system and then
died in the process of resisting arrest
eight months of protests mostly peaceful
where they burned down cities across the
country it's not to Lament The
unfairness here it's just to point out
we have two systems of Justice in this
country if you attack a Democrat they
are going to throw you in the can they
might kill you for even threatening to
maybe sort of get in a position to
attack a Democrat if you attack a
republican they'll giggle about it and
they'll let you off the hook gun rights
are very very important there's a story
out of Houston an armed customer and a
Houston Taqueria
just killed a gun-wielding robber and we
actually have the the footage of it so
the the would-be robber comes into the
Taqueria
and he starts
robbing people at gunpoint
so not just the owner of the Taqueria
he's going around the tables he's
picking up money off the table
brandishing this weapon everywhere
pointing it at all the people reaching
out forcing them to empty their wallets
and then you can see a guy
this older looking ball guy
and he's just
he reaches into his pocket and the
minute that the robber turns he pulls
out his gun perfect form shoots the
robber dead
then this guy goes up to the robber
takes the money out of his hand and
Returns the money
to all the people that he had just
robbed and then this guy
takes his gun out
walks out of this restaurant looking
like Clint Eastwood gets back in an old
Clint Eastwood looking like Gran Torino
kind of truck
from I don't know the 50s and drives out
of there
so of course the authorities are looking
for this man to question him they're
actually they haven't identified him
they want to bring him in for
questioning even though it was all
caught on camera this guy was completely
Justified
in his shooting that's the way the
system works these days
because you're you you can be led off
the hook if you rob people and if you
threaten people with a gun and you
threaten their lives there we have to
feel great pity for you you you're
probably just a result of a broken
system and oh you know how Society
failed this guy but then if you defend
yourself against the gun wielding threat
that that is a far greater problem put
that aside for a second why do I even
mention this story I mention it because
it illustrates a very important rule in
life and that is the F around and find
out rule this is a very very important
rule
people don't follow it as much as they
should
because the saddest part of the story
according to the Houston Police is that
the the now dead suspect who is the one
brandishing the gun everywhere was
actually brandishing a plastic pistol
possibly an airsoft or maybe a little BB
gun type pistol that's according to
k-h-o-u
wasn't even a real gun
a little pellet gun so that what what
happened the guy
busts into this restaurant
to rob people
but he doesn't
want to get arrested for carrying this
deadly weapon
doesn't want to get arrested for
threatening people with this deadly
weapon
doesn't want to
kill people
he clearly doesn't want to kill people
if this guy were really willing to kill
people he would have brought a real gun
but he wasn't
he just wanted to scare people enough
that they would give him their money and
then he could get away and not actually
have to do it
but if you're that Clint Eastwood bald
guy over there
and you're seeing this person waving a
gun that looks really really real at
your head maybe he's saying I'm going to
kill you he's at least implicitly saying
I'm gonna kill you
you have got to react to that to defend
your life and other people in the
restaurant
you've got to react as if that's a real
gun
if you are going to threaten people
you need to be totally willing to make
good on that threat
if you are not
then you are putting yourself in Greater
Danger
it's a lot of the way we talk in this
country it's the a lot of the way we
behave we behave
as though we will face no consequences
for our actions
so we we think it's there's there's no
worry we we do this even on the right
when we talk about Civil War well we're
in the midst of a Civil War in this
country it's a cold Civil War it's a
cultural Civil War are you really ready
to be in a civil war whenever people ask
me do you think Michael the conservative
States should secede do you think we
should get a little more aggressive in
our civil war that we're in this country
I think look maybe you're eager for war
I'm not
I I don't support conservative states
seceding because no
part of a country has ever seceded from
another part of the country in a totally
peaceful way so if you're game for that
you say okay we're leading the secession
okay fine are you willing to shoot your
cousins
are you willing to shoot your neighbors
or the people you know in other states
or I don't know I'm not I'm not there
yet
and I don't think that we ought to be
wielding airsoft guns and BB guns in in
these sort of situations if you're going
to
if you're gonna F around you're gonna
find out okay so if you're gonna if
you're gonna take decisive aggressive
political action you've got to be a
hundred percent serious about it which
is why I think we need wisdom and when
you want true wisdom and peace and the
truth you've got to check out Bible in a
year right now go to ascensionpress.com
Knowles if you're someone who has always
wanted to read and understand the Bible
but you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible linear podcast
is currently the most popular religion
podcast in the United States millions of
people have listened to it and twice
it's hit the number one spot on Apple
podcasts in the Bible in a year father
Mike Schmitz reads the entire Bible in
365 daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way what better way to start the new
year you can find the Bible in a year
podcast with father Mike Schmitz for
free in your favorite podcast app or on
YouTube unlike any other Bible podcast
Bible in a year follows a special
reading plan that organizes the books of
the Bible in a way that helps listeners
understand the story get this reading
plan at ascensionpress.com Knowles kwles
if you want to start reading and more
importantly understanding the Bible this
year go to Ascension press dot com slash
Knowles kwles download the reading plan
for free ascensionpress.com Knowles to
download the reading plan for free
mentioned a little bit earlier about the
anniversary of the death of Ashley
Babbitt
and how the comparison here really shows
you the two-tiered system of justice
well it it goes right to the heart of
the Ashley Babbitt story Ashley
Babbitt's mother was just arrested
Ashley Babbitt's mother
was in Washington DC for the anniversary
of her daughter's death at the hands of
a trigger happy Capitol Hill cop and
Ashley Babbitt's mother wanted to lay
down some flowers for her daughter
and she was arrested
it was our plan to go lay steps flowers
on the steps of the capitol for the four
people unarmed American citizens that
lost their lives that day that would be
my daughter Ashley Babbitt Roseanne
Boylan who was beaten by a metropolitan
police officer Lena Morris Kevin Grayson
and Benjamin Phillips all lost their
lives that day as unarmed American
Patriots so we wanted to lay flowers on
the steps of the Capitol they were
letting people in they had it all
barricaded off they were letting people
in but they would not let us in with our
signs and and uh and our flags and and
so we opted to walk down the street that
was already closed off so we laid
flowers on the east side I'm not sure
which side but and then when we went to
go turn the corner there was no sidewalk
for us to walk on there were other
citizens walking on that sidewalk we
were not allowed to because we had uh
American flags at the United States
capital so um we we walked down the road
as because we had no sidewalk to walk on
and our option was to cross four lanes
of traffic and walk on the other side
where I also would not have been able to
honor my my daughter by laying a rose
for her around the Capitol building and
so we walked on the road and I was
arrested aggressively by one uh that man
right there yeah the one right there the
um tall bald man
what was this woman arrested for
jaywalking basically for jaywalking I
think the actual charge was that she was
arrested for blocking and obstructing
roadways because she walked into some
areas where they had some impediments
set up and she wasn't supposed to be
walking there
blocking and obstructing roadways
black lives matter
shut down highways in LA
Seattle
Massachusetts Washington DC all over the
country I was in multiple places
during the BLM Madness
as the BLM movement shut down those
freeways and highways for hours in some
cases totally blocking traffic nobody
did anything about it and this woman
grieving the killing of her daughter
wants to lay a rose at the people's
house
at the Capitol
and she's not allowed to she gets
arrested for doing that
she says that the cops they knew this
was a bad bad group of people why
because they were waving American flags
had the group been waving Pride Flags
BLM Flags
any of those other Anarchist Flags Che
Guevara Flags you know the cops would
not have done a damn thing to obstruct
them
because those people they would have
been left Wingers
they would have been on the same side as
our current regime
but because Ashley Babbitt's mother and
the protesters were waving an American
flag the cops saw that they said oh this
is a threat
can you imagine how
far has our country Fallen
that these cops they see an American
flag they say that's that's a symbol of
a threat
we've got to go arrest this woman
she shouldn't be she shouldn't be laying
down a rose for her daughter at the
Capitol
our regime affords greater protection to
people who burn the American flag than
it does to people who wave the American
flag
that's not hyperbole
we all know that that is the case if you
if you burn the American flag well
you're probably just an aggrieved victim
of this terrible awful Society this
traditional American country that we're
doing our best to get rid of as quickly
as possible
but if you wave the American flag
why you're probably one of those
far-right extremists we live under a
regime today when I say regime it's it's
unusual language because we usually only
refer to political systems in other
places as regimes we never refer to our
own country as a regime it's only
there's other places where they have
governments that we don't like that's
always the regime but a regime just
means a political order
and so our political order obviously has
transformed pretty significantly over
the last 50 60 years certainly over the
last 200 years
we are not living in the political order
of the founding fathers and the framers
our system of government does not work
like the bill up on Capitol Hill and
Schoolhouse Rock right we live in a very
different one
and and we live in one today where
the Department of Justice refers to
parents who don't want their kids to
have their genitals chopped off and have
their kids be told that they're evil
because they're white refers to those
parents as domestic terrorists
that's the system that we're living in
we're living under a regime where we are
told that people who burn down
courthouses were people who murder
dozens of people over the course of
months where people who threatened to
assassinate top conservative public
officials they're all referred to as
mostly peaceful protesters but the guy
in the horn hat and the smiley Florida
guy who took a picture posing with Nancy
Pelosi's lectern those are
insurrectionist terrorists the greatest
threat to our country that's the regime
we're living in okay and I'm not whining
about it I'm not screaming and crying
I'm just telling you that's how it is
and so when these Court decisions come
down
and if you throw a can at Ted Cruz's
head basically the liberal establishment
just laughs It Off
where a mother grieving the loss of her
daughter wants to lay a rose at the
Capitol and the cops arrest her for it
no you're one of the bad ones you're one
of those conservative ones we're going
to throw you in the in the squad car why
I don't know we don't like the cut of
your jib you looked at us funny you get
in the car
just don't be surprised that's the way
that it is
and it ties right back to the top of
what we're talking about when a handful
of conservatives
those intransigent conservatives
say hey we need a little bit more change
in Washington DC than just getting
another tax cut Bill through
when a group of conservatives say we
need
structural serious change to the way
power is wielded in this country and the
way that we view good and bad and true
and false and the things that we exalt
and the things that we discourage we
need to kind of change that because it's
gotten a little bit of skew I don't
think that those conservatives are the
bad guys
I think they are doing
the most that they can do and the Very
bare minimum of what needs to be done
and I don't think that anyone should
should attack them for it because it
took us three more days to to get Kevin
McCarthy into the speaker Suite which he
already moved into in the first place by
the way he already moved in there before
he even won the vote okay
speaking of January 6th and the attack
on conservatives this is a perfect
example of this actually
the January 6th committee I'm sorry I
didn't pronounce that correctly the
January 6th the worst day in the history
of the world on the January 6 committee
has now been disbanded
they were created
by Nancy Pelosi
is a purely left-wing partisan attack
dog group
they had two fake Republicans on the
committee
Liz Cheney and Adam kinzinger both out
of the Congress right now
and they existed to to get Trump
to get the conservatives and to prove
that the right Wingers are
insurrectionists and to throw everybody
in prison and it didn't work it didn't
work they had nothing it was a complete
joke they accomplished zero and so on
their way out do you know what they did
they leaked the social security numbers
of top Trump officials
they did I was going to say they doxxed
the top Trump officials it's much worse
than that
to leak someone's Social Security number
is worse than leaking some of their
personal contact information
when you leak someone's Social Security
number you are inviting identity thieves
to go in steal their identities destroy
possibly their credit and destroy
their entire
digital Financial possibly professional
life
the January 6 committee did this to
hundreds of Americans
including at least three members of
Trump's cabinet we're not just talking
about kind of anonymous low-level
staffers we're talking about Ben Carson
here they leaked Ben Carson's social
security number why did they do that
was there a was there a legal purpose
that was fulfilled in leaking their
social security numbers no was there an
investigative purpose that was fulfilled
in leaking their social security numbers
no
the January 6 committee
leaked the top conservative Social
Security numbers
to punish them
as as Vengeance for these conservatives
having had the audacity to challenge the
dominant liberal regime
this was the wielding by Democrats using
the executive agencies wielding the
government to try to destroy the people
that they view as their enemies that's
all that is
an official attack by Congress on their
political enemies
but we're told Lauren bobert and Matt
Gates and Chip Roy and Scott Perry
they're the problem they are the ones
who are upsetting the Norms of our
Congress oh they're the ones if only we
didn't have those in-civil absolutely
barbaric
immature
conservatives there uh last I checked
Lauren bobert and Chip Roy haven't
leaked their political enemies Social
Security numbers okay it's just so
absurd
anything that the libs and the squishes
want to accuse the conservatives of
doing to upset the standards and Norms
of our country the Democrats have done
to a degree orders of magnitude
more egregious
of course we're talking about standards
and Norms the entire project of the left
over the last 60 years has been too
upset pervert frankly invert the
standards and Norms of our country that
is why we now call good evil and evil
good and we call false truth and
falsehood truth and truth falsehood
that's the attack that they have made
and so how are we going to fight back
there is some good news coming out of
Kentucky
you know if there's one thing to be
learned from the release of the Twitter
files it's that the establishment media
cannot be trusted you know it we know it
now Millions more people are waking up
to it so no surprise that morning wire
the daily wire's fastest growing News
podcast is continuing to climb the
charts with new episodes seven days a
week join editor-in-chief John Bickley
with co-host Georgia Howe as they cut
through the corporate agenda and
manufactured outrage to bring you the
facts
first on all the news you need to know
wake up with morning wire on daily wire
plus Apple podcast Spotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts
speaking of fighting back against the
enemy
great story out of Kentucky
State Treasurer Allison ball has
published a list of financial
institutions currently boycotting energy
companies
for the ESG agenda for environmentalism
or because Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat yelled at them and so they're
doing that now they're saying no more
oil no more gas and the Kentucky State
Treasurer has required that agencies in
the Commonwealth divest from those firms
so you're saying here's a list of the
ESG people who are wielding the
trillions of dollars in assets that they
manage to to force the companies that
they invest in to push a woke agenda
well Kentucky is not going to be a part
of that
we've seen this happen elsewhere we saw
this happen in Texas we saw this happen
in Missouri we saw this happen in
Louisiana we saw this happen in Florida
Idaho has a bill on this coming up other
states are going to follow suit because
it's a perfect issue for conservatives
and
the only objection to it is going on the
right at least is going to come from the
squishes and a certain breed of
self-styled Libertarians who say well
this is terrible this is the state
bullying a private company that poor
little private company BlackRock those
that little Mom and Pop Shop Vanguard
and State Street the largest asset
managers in the world managing trillions
of dollars in assets all these guys
they're being bullied by that mean old
Allison ball in Kentucky or by mean old
Ron DeSantis or by mean old Greg Abbott
or or their treasurers or the
conservatives elsewhere
this undermines the American Republic
because we have a thriving free market
here
why is it
why is it not an interference in the
free market when a handful of woke asset
managers
push their Fringe radical agenda on
every company in the country against the
will of the American people
but it is an infringement on the free
market when a duly elected public
official does the same thing
or even or when a dually elected public
official does something far more modest
which is to say okay if you're going to
do that we're not going to invest our
money with you BlackRock
why is that free more I like free
markets I do
free markets are a wonderful thing in
their proper place as a means to the end
of a good and flourishing Society
that's what it's for we're not having
the Tail Wag the Dog here folks we're
not putting the cart before the horse
all right the political Community does
not exist to serve the market the market
exists for the good of the political
community
and even if you're the biggest
staunchest defender of free markets in
the world how is this a free market
when three asset managers get to
redefine the entire essentially the
entire National culture
by pushing their crazy views on every
company in the country
that doesn't seem very free to me and if
it were then I wouldn't care for it okay
because I think that self-government
means
that we get to say no to this kind of
stuff okay this is not an undermining of
the American Republic when we tell the
woke investment people to knock it off
that is an expression of self-government
that is Justice okay now speaking of
Justice
there's a group of people
that has come under attack recently I'm
not talking about the white men not
talking about the straight people or the
Christians or the the obviously
the straight white Christian man that is
the most maligned group in all of
society but other people are maligned
sometimes as well one of which groups
was nepo babies
there's been some chatter recently and
lots of think pieces about the nepo
babies
these children who are the sons and
daughters of Hollywood celebrities who
then magically get careers themselves
and Tom Hanks has just come out to
defend
the nepo babies
look this is the family business this is
what this is what we've been doing
forever is what our all of our kids grew
up in we have four kids they're all very
creative they're all involved in some
brand of of Storytelling and if we were
a plumbing supply business or if we ran
you know the florist shop down the
street the whole family would be putting
in time at some point even if it was
just you know inventory at the end of
the year the thing that doesn't change
no matter what happens no matter who
what your last name is is whether it
works or not I mean that goes that
that's the issue anytime any of us go
off and try to try to tell a fresh story
or create something that is has a
beginning and a middle of an end doesn't
matter what our last names are I know
Tom Hanks is a huge lib I know that he
is best friends with Barack Obama I know
that no one has any sympathy for the
nepo babies or for really anybody else
in Hollywood but I gotta say I gotta
call it like I see it
I think Tom Hanks is right
I think actually the principle that Tom
Hanks is articulating here is not only
right
it's right wing
those two frequently overlap
it's actually a deeply conservative
principle
he's saying yeah of course the children
of Hollywood stars have a leg up in Show
Business
it's a family business
and it's not just Hollywood that
operates this way it's every business
if I were a plumber my kid would
probably know a little bit more about
Plumbing than the average kid who grew
up in Hollywood let's say if I were a
plumber
my kid would probably have more
opportunities to break into the plumbing
trade
than someone who is the son of a banker
or someone who's the son of a school
teacher or so
of course we pass on wisdom and
practical knowledge to our children
and we help our families out too
there's nothing wrong with that there's
nothing wrong with showing some degree
of preferential treatment for your
family
and for your local community that is
perfectly natural that's perfectly right
that's perfectly just conservatives used
to know that
I think we still basically get that
we are not just all random individuals
Born Into The Ether with no particular
ties to our own parents over anybody
else's parents or to our own country
over anybody else's country we're not
just atomized citizens of the world
and we're born into particular places
into particular traditions and it's
totally fine to pass on your trade to
your kids and Timex says he says you
know listen my kids have done all right
and they're telling stories to some
degree but if you don't put out a good
product you're not going to last very
long
that's true in any business how many
family businesses get destroyed
is one generation two generations three
generations down the line the kids are
screw-ups and they can't run the
business
happens all the time but merely passing
on a tradition to your family that's a
great thing it's a great thing I hate to
defend Tom Hanks but I have to do it now
on the topic of people that I don't have
to defend and on the topic of nepotism
and on the topic of would-be Hollywood
stars
Prince Harry
Prince Harry and his new tell-all memoir
book by the man who just wants to be
left alone the man who only wants
privacy and that's why he's writing
books and doing Netflix movies and going
on TV to any channel that will have him
Prince Harry
has just admitted
that he has done a lot of drugs a lot
shocking I know he's done a lot of drugs
and the worst part of that is
he says that those drugs have helped him
see the truth
and Prince Harry's life and all the poor
decisions he's making
it's all starting to make sense to me
Harry says that while cocaine made him
feel different it did not make him
notably happier but mushrooms did when
he took magic mushrooms in California
while drinking a lot of tequila that had
a profound impact and here's this here's
this amazing experience he had he says
he saw a bathroom trash can that looked
like it was staring back at him and
growing ahead and then the toilet turned
into a head and began talking to him and
he says this was the experience of a
lifetime man you know because like when
you really want to understand the truth
you know it's not that you should pray
to God for clarity and meditate on the
on the Eternal things and it's not that
you should read a lot of books Say by
wise writers no it's that you should eat
poisonous mushrooms and stare into the
toilet that's going to teach you the
truth man because it's going to like
grow ahead or whatever and then
apparently two years after this
experience what happened Harry married
Meghan Markle okay starting to starting
to make sense now
Harry said he was able to see another
world
and and it it left him with the
impression that this other world is just
as real and twice as beautiful as the
one that we're all living in which is
not all there isn't and Harry said when
he saw this world
only the truth existed
so first of all Prince Harry admitting
to doing all these drugs especially in
the United States could screw up his
visa application this actually could be
a good excuse for the United States to
boot him out because it means he almost
certainly lied on his immigration papers
and if he did not lie and he told the
truth and he was using these illicit
drugs that also would be a reason to
boot him out
but beyond that
hopeful thought for a second
just to the point that Harry is making
I've seen it happen before I have
friends who have done this who have
taken mushrooms or acid more often acid
or one of these even more intense kind
of psychedelic drugs shrooms too though
and they'll say you know man I just saw
and it gave me peace because I saw all
the other beings and they showed me and
I'm not joking I've had friends tell me
and I realized man there's no devil
there's no hell there's no sin
is it what
yeah man I just realized like we're all
one you know we're all one and I saw
these little kind of beings popping out
and I said you saw like you're saying
you saw incorporeal
Spiritual Beings that told you there's
no sense of sin and you don't need to
fear hell
I think you were talking to a demon I'm
pretty sure no man I well then what was
it were you just imagining it no man it
was totally real okay so you're saying
it wasn't just some figment of your
imagination you were talking to a real
it not physical
this is a purely spiritual being that is
telling you don't worry about going to
hell and don't worry about committing
sins that's a demon that's what that's
what demons are that's how demons behave
man and the proof of the pudding is in
the tasting
the proof of the Yorkshire pudding is in
the tasting here for Prince Harry
because it does not seem that his life
has improved when he has done these
things even searching for deeper meaning
you are not going to find deeper meaning
by eating poisonous mushrooms
I remember my friends would ask me and
say Michael don't you want to open up
your mind man see experience the truth
and I thought well I try to do that like
for instance when I go sit outside at
night and read a book like when I read a
really wise deep profound book
that also changes the Pathways in my
brain
that also allows me to see things that I
previously couldn't see before but it
does so without poisoning the most
important organ in my body
and it does so
without opening me up to an experience
that you describe as being a perfect
description of talking to Demons you
know it just allows me to kind of sit
out
think and get smarter in growing wisdom
if only Harry had done that he would be
in a much better spot if only our
culture valued that sort of thing
instead of poisoning ourselves we would
probably be in a better spot too you
know it is music Monday
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles
kwels at checkout for two months free
on all of the annual plans we will see
you at the member block
[Music]
[Music]